in Vegas I tried to put ten thousand
dollars on [ __ ] Nate Diaz oh wow one
and the [ __ ] because I couldn't my
card wouldn't do it my ATM was like my
bank account you could just take ten
thousand dollars I'd like called it just
was a this whole rig about and what
would you have won uh he was he was
slight Underdog yeah yeah yeah uh
probably doubled up 1100 yeah 11 000 12
000. I first yeah shout Sydney first one
have you spoken to him about what the
next plan is can you give us I haven't I
haven't I love that I'm not close I'm
not close but no no stop it stop it stop
it no you're not best friends but you
guys have we're acquaintances outside of
I don't want to keep going on podcast
and be like I mean an idea as a friend
because I I don't want him to think that
I'm out here don't say that your friends
but you guys have hungry so you know
Nate outside of TV and fighting like you
know him just as a guy yes and what
you've said to me is
the best guy I think he's the best dude
I've see you again I go on podcasts and
suck this dude's titties
everybody talks [ __ ] they make fun of
they have little jokes nobody's going
I've hung out with him and he is the
real dude he's the only dude that like
he's the only famous dude that I've seen
that actively will like if you're I'm
not advocating this but like
if people are around and they're like
can we get a picture he's like oh yeah
hell yeah like immediately yeah like no
hesitation yeah he's out having fun with
everybody like the first time I met him
one of his friends McDermott what up
shouted uh he brought me to hang out
with him yeah and right when I got to
the bar they were about to shotgun some
beers and Nate was like he never met me
he was like hold on hold on get him one
like he stopped ever like it was crazy
yeah he's the man that's the nicest dude
possible yeah every other famous person
would be like [ __ ] another that fat
[ __ ] idiot
he was just like get him another drink
so there's this moment I don't know if
you watched like the uh there's a moment
where he's in the I think it was Megan
olivi I think is her name and he's
talked with me this after the final five
of those content Rock shoes yeah yeah
yeah yeah he's thrashing The Rock shoes
shout to rock the rock is a man but but
he's also shout out to the Rock shout
out to rock but he's doing but he's he's
I don't know it's the weirdest thing
like it was the first time I saw like
his I want to say like true personality
yeah he almost feels like I don't know
like he's he's more reserved in the
press conferences and all these other
things like this was him being goofy
like he was being silly it seems like
after fights like he was being funny
after that fight yes and then did you
see them when somebody asked him about
uh kamzat someone was like what'd you
think of that he was like
[ __ ] yeah scared yeah I won I'm wanna
know yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but you
could tell he's sitting up there like
this is funny yeah you know yeah yeah
he's uh yeah he's a [ __ ] man it's
it's one of those things I think the
reason why like people are curious at
least the least reason why I'm curious
when I saw you guys hanging is it like
oftentimes you meet people that are
famous and you're kind of like let down
yeah and every once in a while you meet
somebody famous and you're like oh this
guy is the [ __ ] truth yeah and he is
yes dude every time I'm like I uh
there's a girl at the cellar that's like
obsessed with him yeah so I like texted
him I was hammered and I was like this I
wouldn't do this otherwise I was drunk I
was like [ __ ] it I'll text Nate yeah
yeah it's like dude will you Facetime
real quick this girl [ __ ] loves you
and I was like a minute later he didn't
respond and I text him I was like I'm so
[ __ ] gay for asking
[ __ ] I suck so bad it ruined my night I
was just like [ __ ] dude but then he
facetimed me and I was like oh [ __ ] hold
on and I held it up and she was like
yeah and he was like yeah
what's up what's going like he was just
also he got me for the impression oh
really we went out to dinner that's how
I know these they're watching people are
watching yeah yeah I think I might have
did his impression on Rogan and he was
like we're in the middle of dinner he's
like I don't sound like that no and I
was just like how scared were you in
there I was like agreed
I have not done it since
[Laughter]
it's so nice nah it's great it's
refreshing when they're eyes yes yeah it
was crazy to also like to slightly know
him and then watch him fight I was like
I was in that I felt like yeah yeah a
wife wait you were there yeah I was cage
that I was with Rogan that's right
that's right up front yeah what was sick
as he got done we were at the after
party and he was like I saw you sitting
out front Shane Gillis
I was like damn dude you saw me during
the fight yeah
that's why he won did he was like I
don't [ __ ]
[Laughter]
like what do they look like after a
fight like he was fine really yeah he
was fine
yeah I don't think he
he didn't take too many it was the leg
kicks yeah you got some leg kicks and so
I'm wondering dude he took that one I
was like oh [ __ ] yeah he like limped on
it he made that look easy though yeah I
couldn't believe that yeah Ferguson's
wild yeah
I don't know he's done he looks like
he's trying stuff out yeah did you see
that I just watched a video of him like
kicking a metal pole in this house holy
[ __ ] yes striking that shin bone that's
a terrifying thing yeah yeah like you
stub your toe and it's like the worst 10
seconds of your life yeah this guy's
kicking a metal pole yeah
with the sunglasses on yeah
sunglasses yeah
yeah yeah he's like from the future bro
that's what it feels like he's from the
future if you if we were in the 90s
what's the future
yeah for real he's kicking metal yeah
even his captions you like you see do
you follow him on Instagram no I don't
know phenomenal what are they he doesn't
like really spell words like he'll spell
them like with emojis in them and like
throw random things that yeah he's he
reminds me the kid in high school that
was like run to class you know what I
mean that would like just like Sprint
there with his hands behind his back
and then he just started [ __ ] people
up like it's insane that you just figure
that out yeah he would be yeah here's a
problem do you think he could take Nate
though like if you guys were drunk if I
could could I take Nate like you guys
are both kind of drunk after a fight uh
you start talking some [ __ ] definitely
yeah
dude you start talking to me over it
would be over so sad and sad it'd be so
sad have you hung out with Nick at all
no never no I'm curious about Nick
everybody's seems very rev you know they
held him in pretty high regards yo
that's that's one thing I really respect
about Nate is like through Nate's
success he's always shouting out every
time yeah like he's like Nick Diaz Army
the goat Nick Diaz Army Nick Diaz on me
this guy's the goat like
yeah I wonder what that that whole crew
is tighten it they're great yeah and
they look like they don't look like you
would imagine they're unassuming they're
totally unassuming I mean I've like with
you know I don't want to be gay their
shirts off I'm sure you can tell
I've thought about it
I've pictured every one of them they're
not gonna like me oh no it's so weird I
get like uh
yeah
coolest famous person you met easily
easily easily yeah he was the guy like I
was a fan of his before yeah like a big
fan yeah yeah and then he lived up to it
he lived he's better than most people
yeah yeah like a cool dude yeah but then
I'm always like it happens then I'm
always like I'm always like oh they're
gonna think I sucked yeah
and you'll say that to them I'll say
that to the one dude like what do you
say like Tim McDermott I'll text him and
be like [ __ ] I asked native if you want
to hang out I look like a [ __ ] idiot
[ __ ] dude the whole crew's not gonna
like me anymore they don't even know who
the [ __ ] I am they just keeps seeing me
drunk at parties like yeah yeah I think
he thinks you're a Make-a-Wish dude I
really do I really think they're seeing
me front row he must have been like oh
[ __ ] that guy is he's [ __ ] [ __ ]
that guy that keeps showing up at
parties is [ __ ] he's like die
already
laughs
yeah yeah Nate's the [ __ ] name that's
funny yeah that comes out that calms
that fight that would have been scary
what do you think comes out scary you
know he's wait you saw him uh oh
when you saw him on the undercar oh so
it was like I thought it was kind of I
mean yeah protect yourself at all times
but like the fake hand touch that was
good I thought that was kind of cool
especially knowing the guy's coming up
and wait to fight you like he's trying
to be a bad guy and he's I don't think
he's built for it yeah he seems like he
wants to be liked yeah so he's trying to
be a bad guy and then yeah being okay
being a bad guy is super [ __ ] rare
yeah I don't think I know anybody like
Jake Paul Jake yeah that's his uh he's
like this is amazing
person like in my life you think of all
the people you know everybody wants to
be like yeah those guys trying to touch
gloves
you [ __ ] jerk and Ortiz was also just
doing it because the crowd started
booing it and he didn't want to be
disliked so he was being a little bit of
a [ __ ] and then he tried it and photos
like [ __ ] that